Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video I'll be explaining everything
you need to know about the ending to Venom
and how the various symbiotes in the movie
set up future sequels.
Plus keep watching to the end where I'll reveal
some sneaky easter eggs and little details
you might have missed in the post-credits,
as well as the details of my new Venom giveaway.
In case you hadn't already guessed, of course,
I'll be talking spoilers, so take care if
you haven't seen the movie yet.
At the end of the film, Venom defeats Drake
and Riot by sabotaging their rocket launch
causing it to explode, and Venom initially
appears to perish during the flaming fallout
and says "Goodbye Eddie".
Eddie later has a reunion with Anne who believes
he's free of the symbiote, but it's revealed
that Venom's still alive and there talking
to Eddie in his head.
Anne gets a little suspicious as she notices
Eddie appearing to talk to himself, but he
decides to not tell her yet.
Eddie clearly wants to get back together with
her, and Venom chips in "You belong with us
Annie", a hint that we'll see She-Venom again
in the potential sequel – and I'll talk
more about Anne's She-Venom shortly.
Eddie decides to keep Venom's existence a
secret from Anne for the moment and this scene
reminded me of the end of the first Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man movie where Peter Parker
hides his feelings from Mary Jane, although
they eventually got together in the next movie.
So, what's the future for Venom and his fellow
symbiotes?
Well, the ending sets up how Eddie and Venom
will interact with each other going forward.
Earlier in the movie, we saw that often the
symbiotes will eat their human hosts from
the inside which seems to be why they keep
travelling from planet to planet devouring
their hosts until there aren't any left.
Venom is a bit different from his fellow symbiotes
and he gains an appreciation for Earth after
he climbs up the skyscraper and looks out
over the city in a rather Spider-Man-esque
moment.
Although Venom started off forcing his host
Eddie to do whatever Venom wanted, by the
end of the movie, Eddie has found he can control
Venom more and quiet him down.
Eddie also decides to teach Venom about right
and wrong and how he can't eat or hurt good
people.
Venom needs to eat though, of course, otherwise
he'll end up eating Eddie's insides, and we
discover Venom has a taste for Tater Tots
and chocolate when they go to the store for
food.
Which leads to the scene where Venom eats
the thug who's been shaking down Mrs Chen.
I guess this means that Eddie will have to
keep hunting down bad guys as a way to keep
Venom's hunger at bay!
As for Anne's future, there a big hint to
that in the scene where we discover she's
bonded with the Venom symbiote and has become
She-Venom.
She saves Eddie as he's about to be killed
by Drake's henchmen, then makes out with him
at which point Venom flips from her back to
Eddie.
Venom's reply of "Not today" when she demands
to join the fight against Riot is a tease
that She-Venom will be back for a much bigger
part in a possible Venom sequel.
And, of course, Anne did end up fighting ugly,
as she put it, when she disabled Riot temporarily
during the Rocket launch sequence by turning
up the loudspeakers.
The Venom sequel is also going to have an
even more powerful villain than Riot, which
I'll explain next, and I think Eddie and Venom
will likely need Anne's She-Venom powers against
him.
OK, so Venom's next villain is set up in the
first post-credits scene where we see Eddie
making his way to San Quentin Prison.
As he mentioned previously to Anne, he's got
a job reporting again and has what he calls
the interview of a lifetime with serial killer
Cletus Kasady.
In this scene, we finally meet Woody Harrelson
who has said that his tiny role in this film
sets him up for a much bigger part in a Venom
sequel.
The prison guard calls Kasady "Red" a little
reference to the villain's red hair and the
red and black colour of the Carnage symbiote
which bonds with Kasady in the comics.
As Kasady talks to Eddie, he threatens that
when he gets out of prison there'll be carnage,
a very on-the-nose nod to the fact we'll be
seeing Kasady become a host for the Carnage
symbiote in the next movie.
In the comics, Eddie Brock and Cletus Kasady
end up sharing time in prison together, something
the movie alludes to by the fact that the
imprisoned Kasady asked specifically for Eddie
to interview him.
In the books, Kasady became Carnage when Eddie's
pregnant symbiote gave birth and the spawn
attached itself to Cletus.
In the film, Eddie told Venom to keep quiet
during the visit and I didn't see any hint
of the symbiote leaking out during what we
saw of Eddie's time there.
So, unless Kasady's already been exposed to
a symbiote off screen, how will he end up
as Carnage?
Well, we need to recap what symbiotes are
still left by the end of the Venom movie and
how Kasady will be exposed to one.
The LIFE Foundation extracted 4 distinct symbiote
samples from the comet.
There was the black one, Venom, who currently
inhabits Eddie.
There was a blue one and a yellow one and
each of those died in the movie when their
hosts died, one of which was Jenny Slate's
character, Dr Dora Skirth.
The fourth sample was Riot, the symbiote which
escaped after the LIFE Foundation's space
craft crashed in Malaysia.
Riot hopped around from host to host passing
from the EMT technician, to the old woman
in the market, then to the little girl at
the airport and finally on to Drake.
But Riot died together with Drake during the
rocket explosion; remember there are just
two things which can kill a symbiote: fire
and a sustained sound above a certain frequency.
What's even more important to recall though
is that there are millions of other symbiotes
still on that comet that is presumably passing
through or near our Solar System.
And debris that breaks off from comets often
ends up as meteorites when they fall into
the Earth's atmosphere.
What if a red symbiote fell to Earth via a
meteor?
It might even crash-land in San Quentin prison
and help Cletus Kasady escape!
By the way, in the comics, Carnage is such
a powerful villain that Venom has typically
teamed up with Spider-Man and the Fantastic
Four to combat the evil symbiote.
At the moment, Sony's deal with Marvel Studios
means Spider-Man can only appear in the MCU,
not any of Sony's current films; however,
after Avengers 4 and Spider-Man: Far From
Home, Tom Holland's Peter Parker will have
appeared in 5 MCU movies and it's possible
that Sony could pull Spider-Man back into
their own Marvel Universe to appear in a Venom
sequel.
Bonus easter egg time now: The way Kasady
writes 'Welcome Eddie' in blood inside his
cage is a little hat-tip to how his character
leaves the phrase 'Carnage Rules' in various
places in the comics.
If you didn't manage to stay all the way through
the very long and pretty slow-moving credits,
you probably missed the second end-credits
scene which was a tease for Sony's animated
Spider-Man Into The Spider-Verse movie.
The scene begins with a comic-book pop-up
graphic "Meanwhile in another universe" indicating
that the animated movie exists in a different
reality to the Venom movie.
What we see next is not a trailer, but a full-length
scene.
The animation on show looks fantastic, however,
because it doesn't have any impact on Venom
or any future Venom sequel, it feels a little
disconnected so it's basically just an extended
advert.
Of course, Marvel has simply shown scenes
from upcoming movies as post-credit scenes,
however, they do all exist within the same
universe so it doesn't feel quite as odd.
Now, if you enjoyed Venom, what was your favourite
moment in the movie?
Or if you didn't like it, let me know why
in the comments below!
For a chance to win an awesome Venom Funko
Pop, just make sure you're a subscriber and
leave me a comment about the movie.
The winner of my Captain Marvel Funko Pop
is on screen now, and if you're the winner,
message me via email to claim the prize.
Tap left to watch my Marvel playlist or tap
right for another video you're sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this video, I really appreciate
a thumbs-up and a share!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!